[Music]  there's one thing you should know about  me I specialize in a very specific type  of security subconscious security you're  talking about dreams  [Music]  mr. Cobb has a job offer he would like  to discuss with you  okay work placement  not exactly we create the world of the  dream we bring the subject into that  dream and they fill it with their  secrets then you break it and still it  well it's not strictly speaking leaving  it's called inception  I think I found a way home  and this last job  feel real while we're in them Zoe when  we wake up that we realize something was  actually strange  it's your responsibility they're not  prepared to this  treats classic  I have it under control  I'd hate to see out of control  you mustn't be afraid to dream with a  bigger down it  [Music]